[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
well happy wednesday
welcome
to let's talk the tony michaels podcast
it is noon eastern 11 central you know
what time that is
it is time
to go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends on the [ __ ] list roundup
today
[Music]
we're still scrambling to get this show
together we got a lot of stuff going on
i told you we have a very important
interview that we're gonna release this
week uh we're still we're still working
on a few things still working on getting
it done it is
it's very significant it's a story that
everyone wants to know they they want to
know this story everyone wants to know
this story
uh
so stay tuned
of who this interview is going to be
with uh it's with a couple of folks who
uh know a few things or two
about the january 6th insurrection and
people who were involved
uh everyone's saying hello hello hello
hello hello
hello yoda good morning [ __ ] and
buckets
hello mj good morning good morning good
morning all good morning thanks for
joining us here
on the tony michael's podcast we're
going to do the [ __ ] list round up here
in a minute
but i do want to go through some
announcements um sorry i don't have a
hard time uh good morning good morning
robin good morning everyone everyone's
joining in here everyone's typing in the
hellos hellos hellos
uh if you guys don't know you can go
over to youtube now
the [ __ ] list roundup the tony michaels
podcast is every single weekday
noon eastern 11 central for two full
[ __ ] hours
full two hours and uh we've got
we've got um some special stuff coming
up in the and today or tomorrow or
friday we're still trying to work this
out now we we recorded a big interview
there's a lot of news to to that is in
this interview that we want to get out
and we're just trying to make sure
that as many eyeballs see it that can
see it and we're getting it cut and and
you know you know like put together and
edited you know the thing that gabe does
you know uh we're doing that the the
video thing you know he's good at the
the video editing so he's doing all that
i'm getting it getting it close to
release we may have a teaser clip for
you today it is possible that we could
do that we just are uh trying to get
trying to get all the ducks in a row i
guess you'd say so we're working on that
but you tune in today because we're
gonna do the [ __ ] list roundup gabe's
gonna join us here in a bit um i also
think i have a senate candidate from
arkansas natalie james i don't know if
you guys know natalie but if you don't
you're going to today i believe she's
going to come up at the top of the
second hour is when natalie will be
joining us for a bit she wants to talk
about act blue a lot of democrats don't
know how to donate or what act blue is
uh she was explaining it in a space one
day and i said you know what why don't
you come on the show
and just explain it to all the viewers
we'll we'll package it together we'll
put it up on youtube that way people can
go over to youtube and watch that video
of you explaining
what your version of act blue is so
natalie
a senate candidate and the state of
arkansas is going to join us so
subscribe to the youtube channel that
way
if you missed that little clip we'll cut
it out and post it on youtube for
everyone to see that way we gotta we got
a link to spread around
you know spread those links around like
herpes around the interwebs i guess
boy everyone's saying hello hello hello
in the uh in the chat here welcome
welcome welcome to the podcast
um we're gonna do the shitless roundup
today
uh and gabe's gonna join us we're still
waiting on to see
if we're going to
air a clip of the interview that we have
ready are almost ready for you guys
we've almost got a really special
interview
ready teasing it you know just just
laying it out there just teasing you but
we gotta and we got a nice clip that we
that we put together so let's go to a
quick break and when we come back we'll
do
the [ __ ] list roundup we'll be right
back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your part in blanket
today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
the tony michaels podcast wednesdays at
4 p.m eastern 3 p.m central watch live
on youtube on twitter and twitch
download on apple and spotify now here's
tony
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging in with us there on
the break
who's ready
to go through the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends huh let's go to the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends i'll make
it a little smaller for now uh there's a
lot of stuff going on let's see what
what do we have as far as trending
topics today of course it's groundhog's
day that [ __ ] scene is shadow uh
jeff zucker the ceo or whoever the [ __ ]
he is runs cnn uh he's resigning i guess
uh good luck a whoopi goldberg was
suspended and uh mary trump's leaving
spotify chris cuomo's trending j crew
and john kennedy is trending because
john kennedy's
a [ __ ] idiot uh josh hawley and
lindsey graham also are two senators
that are trending i'm not sure exactly
why probably because they're [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] oh i know why lindsay's i
don't know why lindsay's trending uh
because donald trump said he was a he
was a rhino i guess i don't know
lindsay said something crossways to
trump and uh his boyfriend got butt hurt
so now they're now they're in a fight
they're gonna break up probably and then
they'll they'll go golfing they'll kiss
and make up no get back together all
right
let's go to the [ __ ] let's let's go
to the [ __ ] [ __ ] list roundup start
the countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the
shitless roundup where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
of today let's just get right into it
it's not waste much time and a lot of
news going on i guess and today
uh first things first i seen this video
by david pepper i want to come back to
this um it's a very interesting a little
clip here that i want to come back to
and it's about ohio and how ohio is
trying to rig their elections hmm
it isn't democrats trying to rig it
guess who it is a [ __ ] gqp of course
it is um also there's this [ __ ] slime
ball that i want to show you a clip of
right wing watch had posted it um the
shane vaughn i think his name is this
[ __ ] weirdo absolute [ __ ] weirdos
these people are so [ __ ] concerned
about other people's genitalia and
sexuality and [ __ ] it's [ __ ] weird
it's [ __ ] weird that you people sit
around thinking about this type [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing
maybe that's why josh holly is [ __ ]
trending he's jacking off to porn too
much and he hates porn because it makes
him it makes him stressed i don't know
who the [ __ ] can tell
rachel posted a an article here uh by
dana milbanks about glenn youngton's no
guilt history for virginia for fragile
white people it might be worth a read
oh here here we go here we go here's the
news uh stewart rhodes will not stay in
oklahoma we'll also spill his guts to
the january 6 select committee the
cheetah dust mobster might need a few
more packs of diapers
i wonder i wonder i wonder
uh scott had
posted this
rob also broke the news that uh stuart
rhodes uh request to be tained in texas
uh was denied he's apparently in an
oklahoma
uh uh detention center federal detention
center uh but they denied his request to
stay in texas for uh
up leading up to his trial uh his
attorneys argued that they need him
close by to prepare
and the judge said [ __ ] you no denied
you're going to dc
but it looks like today is the day
because this was their argument uh last
week
uh to
let him out of detention was to testify
in front of the january 6th select
committee and be deposed let's give
scott some credit here well while i'm
thinking about it if we read it we get
credit we get credit i'm gonna give rob
credit here too um
and i'll retweet this this is his report
here
i retweeted
it's got there but there you go reddit
you get credit there's the story that
the motion was denied uh to stay in
texas during his trial the judge told
him to [ __ ] right off okay so um the
other news in stuart rhodes as well
is
uh where is that
i think yeah here it is okay look at
this guy with the [ __ ] eye patch
everyone everyone wants to know how he
shot his eye out everyone says one thing
i don't think that's actually the story
and why he wears the patch
okay scott says last night his defense
lawyers told me stuart rhodes was
waiting for a zoom link to use to appear
appear virtually before the house select
january 6 committee today
um so this is this is happening today
possibly on zoom rhodes will appear from
oklahoma prison facility
his defense attorneys will appear from
texas so they'll both be remote
the committee is from dc of course so
they're going to do a zoom call and
question the the pirate here i mean
excuse me mr mr stewart rhodes the
seditionist
uh the eq
the indicted
the indicted accused seditionist
okay we read that we give credit scott
gets a lot of credit here on the show he
does a lot of reporting with stuart
rhodes i think this is very significant
um stewart rhodes as you know is the the
former leader of the oath keeper
uh he started the oath keepers uh he
grew the oath keepers the oath keepers
were involved in several national events
one of them being the bundy ranch and
also
a lot of trump rallies and leading up to
the january 6 insurrection they played a
role they're accused of having a
stockpile of guns across the potomac
ready to bring across as soon as the the
president at the time the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy
declared
martial law after he enacted the
insurrection act yeah that you know they
they were counting on a lot of things
here
let's see what else news do we have uh
brett did a good video yesterday you
guys should go watch this um on the
scotus picks
uh maybe we'll play this later on in the
show and it talks it really shows jen
saki crushing uh ted cruz's words so he
did that video
[Music]
oh oh here we go here we go here we go
here we go here's the whoopee story
everyone's uh you know
you're either pissed off or you're not
pissed off or you think she's racist or
something you know there's a lot of
opinions out there about whoopi what
whoopi said but i said last night let's
go the let's go brandon nazis call
whoopi goldberg a racist yeah okay
so this is the thing like i i get you
know some people are very upset about
what whoopi said and what she said
probably wasn't the most um articulate
thing to say the way she said it right
uh agreed she apologized um i i i think
the apology was sincere it seemed
sincere to me the thing is about this
whole story now she's suspended for two
weeks and i believe the reason why she's
suspended is because racist white
fragile males
got all butthurt about equity oh you're
gonna suspend this person but you're not
gonna suspend whoopi for saying this get
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] so
they suspended whoopi goldberg for two
weeks you know whatever abc has the
right to do that um you know it's in her
contract i'm sure somewhere that she can
be suspended for certain things i mean i
mean they can probably axe her contract
for saying uh other things if they
wanted to
but they suspended her for two weeks and
the way i see it is because the let's go
brandon nazis were really butt hurt
about equity and equality you have to be
fair this is so unfair donald trump jr
was tweeting something about roseanne
barr or some dumb [ __ ]
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] booger sugar
junior now let's see
what else do we have here oh speaking
speaking speaking of booger sugar junior
i found this video of it to be very
interesting paulie teaks has more fun
with cokie mccokehead of course i call
him booger sugar jr he looks like he's
at a shooting range i don't know what
let's play and see what this is
oh what the
oh yeah
nice music
yeah it is awesome
[Laughter]
oh my god paul
lee
teaks you just
he never disappoints does he uh that's
what we do on the show we do important
interviews with united states senator
candidates
and we also show don junior shooting
dicks uh that's how we do but
let's see what else what other kind of
news do we got here on my feed
oh oh oh looky here looky here looky
here
um you guys you guys know we like to
play the parody commercials and um
um i think this one's gonna make its way
into the loop uh maybe maybe we'll wait
for gabe to come on to play this one uh
you know we had missy modell on monday
as our guest interview you guys should
go watch that that interview we're
probably going to re-air that interview
this weekend on its own so you guys can
watch uh just the missy interview
she's super talented super smart
super fun to play trivia with and she's
in this video with gabe this new parody
commercial that you guys love so much so
we will we will try to get the missing
model interview out but maybe when gabe
comes on here in just a bit i think he's
going to be joining us
probably in the next 15 20 minutes
something like that
um and we'll we'll play this we'll play
this video all right and and then we'll
put it in the rotation of the uh of the
commercials because we did we did ask
missy if she would allow us to she said
yes
she said yes so we're gonna have the
uh that in the commercial okay oh here
here we go here's some news here's some
news um we have um grandpa poopypants
did an interview with uh i don't know uh
[ __ ]
newsmax i guess this is i don't know
some kind of [ __ ] propaganda channel
yeah newsmax
it's newsmax i don't know who this
[ __ ] weirdo is um i mean i know who
this fat weirdo is i don't know who this
weirdo is over here who thinks it's a
good idea to interview this [ __ ] like
he's the president of the united states
listen to this dumb [ __ ] that he says
listen to this [ __ ]
you talked about the potential if it's
appropriate of pardoning some of the
january 16th yeah yeah yeah he did he
did he did threaten the united states of
america and the justice department with
pardons that he that the power of a
pardon that he doesn't possess
right he does he doesn't have
the [ __ ] power to pardon anyone
why are we still pretending that he why
why the [ __ ] are you people still
pretending he's the president
it really is you know i say it we're at
the intersection of wrestlemania in real
life this is this is
this is a prime example of what i'm
talking about right here they're [ __ ]
pretending they're producing reality tv
on newsmax like this guy's going to
pardon these people next week or some
dumb [ __ ]
lindsey graham said a couple days later
he thinks that's inappropriate
what do you think well lindsey graham's
wrong
i mean lindsay's a nice guy but he's in
rhino
lindsay's wrong
look
what do you mean lindsay's wrong you
can't pardon them you're not the
president you dumb [ __ ] what
are you talking about
how can you possibly be this [ __ ]
gullible right like how can you possibly
be this gullible if you're walking
around out there
thinking that this guy could pardon
these people he's not the [ __ ]
president he can say whatever the [ __ ]
he wants he's inciting violence is what
he's doing because he doesn't have the
power to pardon anyone and really
honestly he had the [ __ ] power to
pardon him at one point
he could just pardon all of them if he
wanted to
he could have just said you know and
wrote it on his [ __ ] mcdonald's
napkin i pardon all those who are
charged with any crimes due to january 6
especially if it has to do with me
pardoned
federal state you know he just [ __ ]
pardoned him
nope didn't do that
he didn't do that
he had the chance to pardon these
[ __ ] and he didn't
now he's on newsmax pretending like he's
the president they're playing the
reality tv show president here
acting as if this guy can [ __ ] pardon
somebody what the [ __ ] are you people
talking about
he's inciting violence is all he's doing
and newsmax is contributing to it
of course
you know the on brand for them he's
[ __ ] and this is why lindsey graham is
trending
is because he called he called lindsey
graham a rhino
i don't give a [ __ ] lindsey graham is a
piece of [ __ ]
so
just because just because lindsey graham
crosses words with his boyfriend here
means they're gonna
trump's gonna break up with lindsay with
lady g until they go golfing then he'll
hold some russian compromise over
lindsay's head
you know that way lindsay gets back on
the train of yeah we should pardon all
those people again they're political
prisoners and all this [ __ ]
but this is the one this is the one
video
this is the clip that i like the best
here right here this one right here this
one right yeah
right yeah
here we go some of them are being
treated very unfairly yeah i would
absolutely give them a pardon the
punishment things don't work out fairly
punishments are out of proportion to the
crime out of proportion like 20 times
out of proportion
oh please please president biden
pardon me when i get charged
i mean he's like begging
he's begging the president united states
who has the pardon power because he
doesn't you don't
trump is not the president of the united
states you dumb [ __ ]
he's not what are you
what are you doing why are you even
pretending this is a thing like where's
vince mcmahon where's the [ __ ] you
know oh yeah
they need to really like have guys with
no shirts and and like
tights and stuff you know sunglasses and
[ __ ] you know saying all kinds of cool
phrases into the camera ripping their
shirts open i mean really they need to
go full on wrestlemania here they need
to stop dancing around
and just doing this trumps the pretend
president [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about
again he's inciting violence here
because what he's trying to do is tell
not only the january six people who are
in prison i know i didn't pardon you
before and i said i would because that's
the thing here
that's the thing here isn't it
i i i'm gonna pardon you when i become
president again but the only way i can
become president is if you commit
violence and make me the president
because i definitely am not gonna get
elected not enough [ __ ] people like
me
the [ __ ] he and what he's saying to the
january six people who are [ __ ]
locked up the political prisoners
he's projecting to them don't flip on me
and i'll give you pardons and they're
like you [ __ ] i can't even
imagine like can you imagine you were so
[ __ ] delusional that you went to
washington dc and committed [ __ ]
sedition for this [ __ ] you
committed sedition for this [ __ ]
there are reports that [ __ ] congress
members of congress
pimped pardons to these [ __ ] these
these [ __ ] people
who committed sedition
right now there's 11 of them charged
with conspiracy of sedition
11. now other people are charged with
like putting their feet on pelosi's desk
taking documents you know smearing their
[ __ ] on the wall breaking windows [ __ ]
like that
others have
pled guilty to other charges up from
that
but the heaviest charges that we've seen
and of course you know we were just
talking about stuart rhodes being
detained
in oklahoma uh spilling his guts to the
january 6 select committee today
apparently um i don't know if that's
going to happen or not i guess we'll the
time will tell
and will be reported if that deposition
was given
with his attorney's present on a zoom
call
but it appears
it appears that stuart rhodes is going
to spill his guts
but i love i love this
if you look here let me let me move the
banner here
you see the you see the little words at
the bottom here on newsmax it says
reflecting on jan 6 protest
the jan 6 protest
you mean the the cheeto dust kangaroo
coup attempt
they're charged with seditious
conspiracy to overthrow the government
of the united states that's what they're
charged with
um so
it really is uh [ __ ] hilarious
that these people are still pretending
that this guy's the [ __ ] president
we really are at the intersection of
wrestlemania in real life it's a [ __ ]
thing
okay
oh no did you hear um we got cold
weather coming into the country and
texas is possibly going to receive
some cold weather and of course in texas
now greg abbott and the um the the
republicans in texas did not a [ __ ]
thing
about the power grid in texas not a god
damn thing i mean they really made sure
to to work on women's taking away
women's liberty and taking away the the
the right of people in texas who have a
uterus to decide what happens to that
uterus i mean they made sure to do that
they also made sure that it was very
easy for people to spread around the
deadly pathogen you know you got to have
those things power grid and you know we
got to put that on the back burner
so my question was has anyone spotted
the snow lizard on his way to cancun
because you know ted cruz is probably
already looking up tickets
um if he can book a flight to cancun i
don't know maybe maybe he's going
somewhere else this year
as the snow lizard
were to leave as the texas power grid
fails because republicans destroy
everything
they destroy everything they do nothing
but destroy
everything democrats are the only ones
that deliver like literally if the event
would have happened last year and
there'd be democrats in power in texas
you could do something about it the
power grid probably would be in much
better shape today
and ready for a [ __ ] cold event in
texas
probably would be hmm wonder wonder
[Music]
um
what was the other videos oh yeah this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] rube right wing
watch posted this video his name is
shane vaughn
um this guy's a [ __ ] sick gross
homophobe but this guy he has fantasies
about people [ __ ] dogs and [ __ ] i'm
serious i'm dead serious i'm not [ __ ]
around
i don't know where this guy's from i
have no idea just says he's a maga
pastor he's a he's a pastor for
for uh for for trump you know trumpism
he's a trumpism pastor that's their
religion here
um but he's a he's a complete utter
gross homophobe but he talks about how
people should be [ __ ] dogs
i'm gonna play it
but if you look in the background here
he's got the you know toto
so i don't know if this guy's from
kansas because he's got toto everywhere
toto i love toto toto toto so he's got
this obsession with dogs
listen what the [ __ ] he says about dogs
and people [ __ ] them listen how many
remembers when homosexuality was a shame
yeah we we remember when it was a shame
and you should stay the [ __ ] out of
people's lives what the [ __ ] is with you
weirdos
i'm completely obsessed with with who
someone else who has consensual sex with
someone else what the [ __ ] who do you
why do you give such a [ __ ]
jesus christ
maybe maybe pay attention to [ __ ] that
matters but let's let's continue with
this [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
you shouldn't even show your face you
would be worse than a leper
gonna lay up with another grown man
really projecting there
there's shane
you're really projecting there look look
at the face when he says that look at
the face of guilt
that he has i don't know i'm just saying
it looks like he's guilty of what he's
saying right he looks like he's ashamed
of himself i'm just saying
you'd be worse than a leper
what what the [ __ ] a leper what the [ __ ]
does that even mean
leprosy is like a rash
that you get
gay isn't contagious you dumb [ __ ] are
you saying are you saying you caught gay
from someone is that what you're scared
of
you people really are [ __ ] boneheaded
sexuality isn't contagious you dumb
[ __ ]
oh they can't judge me yes we
can
and yes we must
here we go and because we've stopped
here we go
our children
have turned into nightmares yeah that's
what it is we've st you've stopped
judging
you've stopped judging and and the kids
have turned into what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
because because people are more open
about their sexuality because people
aren't gonna [ __ ]
kill them
what
beat them in the streets
yeah they're a little more open about it
nowadays because people don't give a
[ __ ] like you you closeted [ __ ]
no shame
go sleep with who you want to sleep with
go do like an old dog and go with every
little
yeah i'm gonna call them what my grandpa
called female dogs every one of them
walks through the yard mount one of them
do you hear that he wants people to [ __ ]
dogs
what kind of sick [ __ ] loves
toto has all this total [ __ ] all around
him
what who who is this guy who the [ __ ] is
this guy
and who the [ __ ] is he preaching
trumpism to
he's telling people to go [ __ ] dogs
what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] weirdo
you're a bunch of animals
you need the holy ghost
these people with their voodoo right
these people with their voodoo he's like
the holy ghost makes me not you know
think about the the thoughts that i have
so that maybe they'll help you or some
[ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about
to move inside of you and take control
of your passion
because you see his face look at look at
this guy's face when he says that oh you
need the holy ghost to help you control
your passion like he's speaking from
experience watch this guy
oh
please look at
you ever seen
[Music]
i'm not
i'm just trying i'm just trying to
evaluate this video here don't [ __ ]
blame me i didn't [ __ ] put this [ __ ]
on the internet i mean i'm playing it on
the internet
but you know he really he really this is
really a face of guilt here isn't it
don't you believe this let's let's
continue here with this
[ __ ] maga [ __ ]
remember when it was a shame
to be a lesbian you wouldn't what is a
lesbian
what is that
is she saying lesbian because it sounds
like i mean listen listen
lesbian
it's lesbian i mean that's how i say it
lesbian
you wouldn't have shown your face
rightly so
this guy just this guy is just
pure gold here
[Applause]
i mean every every reason why every
reason why we just need to not have this
kind of [ __ ] anywhere i'm going to
retweet
homosexuality was a shame
oh my god this [ __ ] you should turn
him off turn him off turn him the [ __ ]
off turn him off i'm sick of this [ __ ]
who is this guy where is he from
where is he from is he from kansas
because he's got all this total [ __ ]
he's telling people to go [ __ ] dogs it's
really [ __ ] weird it really is
[ __ ] weird that these are the same
[ __ ] that were bitching about
people going in bathrooms and they're
all [ __ ] freaked out about people's
genitalia they're freaked out about
people's
it really does seem like [ __ ]
projection it really does uh welcome
welcome welcome we have we have a guest
with us here um
hey gabe you come in it
you see see
that the mic the mic you know it's just
i i want to be respectful in the green
room you know you're saying some funny
stuff i don't want to laugh too hard
where everyone's like where's this
ominous secret lap coming from
well you know did you watch this video
of this [ __ ] guy no i read the i read
the caption from
or from the right oh right when you
watch oh yeah it's it's gold we just we
just we we took it it's uh let's see
it's 30 some seconds 40 seconds or so
and we we evaluated it even the
background um you know i know yeah i
heard the background so you don't know
where he is i mean someone says shane
vaughn yeah well he's got a lot of toto
stuff in the background so either he has
a fetish with dogs because he's telling
people to go [ __ ] him and he can't say
[ __ ] on the air like he was trying to
he was trying to say [ __ ] you know like
a [ __ ] dog but he didn't want to say
the word [ __ ] i mean he wanted to but
he didn't maybe they should come up with
like a code where like let's go brandon
is his [ __ ] joe biden maybe they should
run into the code word for uh well yeah
because he was oh mississippi
oh he's in mississippi but he's obsessed
with toto so it's a dog fetish that he
has yeah i mean like those guys are
always fetish and fetishizing yeah we'll
have a fetish with uh
because i'm reading an article right now
from newsweek that says pastor shane
vaughn criticized christians who wear a
mask for living their life in fear not
faith and said god told him covenant 19
is
never leaving until people
get that faith oh well god told him so
well then
harvest ministries
yeah he's he's he's definitely i'm not i
mean i'm i'm i don't know anything about
shane other than he wants people to have
sex with dogs and he's he's completely
terrified of uh either someone else's
gayness or maybe his own i don't know
but he's he has a lot of guilty faces
when he says so he does love toto well
if you look is that in a weird like well
and he's got total here there's toto
down here if you look over here there's
some kind of book it looks like i don't
know maybe he wrote it it says toto on
it like this guy
maybe a wizard of oz fan well yeah but
it's not i mean it yes it is wizard of
oz but look it's good
yeah it's it's it's a weird obsession
with a dog and then he's talking about
[ __ ] dogs
it's kind of weird
these people are weirdos i mean we've
been over this you know time and time
again and i'm sure i'm sure this [ __ ]
will pop up somewhere um anne says shane
vaughn is his name yes that it that is
his name shane vaughn and and gabe is
saying
reporting here live on the tournament
yes this guy's like in mississippi oh
wait hold on hold on he's called prof oh
man i just
[Music]
here i'm going to send you the link
right now and you pull this up it's a
facebook page you don't need to know you
don't be on facebook to see it so uh
here i want to get one of the guilty
faces there's one of the guilty faces
that he professor toto is what he's
called bringing
uh to america a revival of the republic
bishop shane vaughn aka professor toto
professor like so this is like a moniker
that he holds
yeah okay i see it here okay so let me
let me let me pull this up here
i just want to double check you weren't
like tricking me or something i didn't
want to bring up any like dog
porn or anything this guy's obsessed
with dogs so i didn't want him
um oh
so this is uh bringing to america the
revival of the republic
uh
bishop shane aka professor toto holy
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on so yeah so
there must be some i don't know what it
is you know about toto but he loves it
and he is
you know self-proclaimed professor toto
wow well
fantastic fantastic so if you uh if you
run into professor toto out there i
guess you know give him a shout out or i
don't know who let the dogs out i don't
know i'm not sure what the who let toto
out yeah there there you go there you go
well i mean did you see well let me let
me um because you said you haven't seen
this video yeah yeah let me
get to the part wow he's very very
animated oh yes here here here we go
here we go
our children
have turned into
nightmares no shame no shame go sleep
with who you want to sleep with go do
like an old dog and go with every little
i'm gonna call them what my grandpa
called female dogs every one of them
walks through the yard mount one of them
see
i told you he tells everybody go mount
one of them like the dog every one of
the dogs that go through the yard go why
do i feel like what the [ __ ] in front of
the camera he's like i won't call what
my granddad called him but then behind
closed doors he's like just reaching
that bit like he was just oh yeah yeah
oh yeah he's calling his children and
his wife [ __ ] yeah like
i just
feel like
and that he like he caught himself he's
like can't say what my granddad said
okay [ __ ] what you know yeah i mean i
mean really technically if we're talking
about like vernacular and stuff when you
call a female dog a [ __ ] it's not
technically a cuss word right i mean or
yeah i mean that's what i don't know i
mean there maybe is a correction you
can't say it anymore but obviously that
is that is what a female dog is or at
least was again i don't know if that's
changed but
yeah well so i don't go calling female
dogs a [ __ ] all right
bites me and i'm like ah you [ __ ] you
know mean i might
but i mean i might call i might call a
male dog a [ __ ] like right you know
like uh like uh steve doocy asked a dumb
question and joe biden leans in mike
said you son of a [ __ ] i mean you might
you might do something like that right
right yeah yeah i'm just saying yeah i
mean it makes a lot of names but you
know he's scared to say the vernacular
of the the word [ __ ] that isn't a cuss
right right yeah i don't know this was
too much respect for the dog but for the
humans [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah right
right right right you gotta love toto
you gotta love the dogs gotta take care
of the dogs i mean they take care of you
right but these humans right
right [ __ ] those humans especially
especially if they have the the feelings
out in the open that i might have you
know here in my exactly it's like oh god
forbid they were able to express
themselves in the way that i want to
trust myself because i've been
suppressing these feelings my whole life
oh you [ __ ] yeah you know i'm not
cheney's closet i'm just saying it it
looks really suspicious yeah i mean it's
also not uncommon for people on the side
to like attack people for the things
that they want that they wish they could
be right that they wish they could
express themselves
right and i think there's that feeling
of envy to be uh
of uh you know a little bit jealous be
like i wish i could you know i could be
true to myself you know
but unfortunately i live in a city oh
yeah
look at this and and have a have a way
to express themselves properly
um this this i found this commercial
and uh maybe we'll put it in the
rotation here oh man your new sponsor
yeah i think so i think so um everyone
knows we had missy on on monday missy
modell
m-o-d-e-l-l go follow her on twitter and
like tweet tweet her a lot mm-hmm
she showed up this morning is she really
oh yeah i didn't know like
like phil the groundhog she came up oh
yeah she's like what what oh six more
weeks of winter okay see you later and
then she
no go
go go tag her uh mention her as much as
you possibly can we're trying to get
we're trying to get missy
over to to twitter but um this this this
commercial popped up and it looks like
some familiar faces let's let's see this
commercial here are you annoyed by masks
infringing on your rights do you wish
you didn't have to comply with biden's
communist mask mandate are you tired of
wearing masks that actually fit your
face
well now you don't have to be
introducing
with our patented droop technology every
mask is uniquely molded to not fit your
face just send us a selfie and we'll
have one of our troopers mold the mask
for you elastic free thanks to the droop
i don't even need to pull my mask on
anymore it just sags that way the droop
lets you customize from a selection of
pre-worn masks lipstick stains included
make sure to order your droop today drew
be the spread you want to see in the
world
the best one of the best images is is
this one here why did you why did i
wonder why they chose a skull like a
dead body um you know i just think it
was uh
you know it was like
just easy er to do that you know
uh
if i had to get i i was like i don't
know what the the editor and creator of
the video was thinking but
if i had to put right myself in their
shoes
um they were probably trying to use it
as like a symbol of some sort to say
like oh uh you're you know you don't
wear a mask or you don't usually wear a
mask the right way then
you know like veteran yoda said let's go
darwin and uh you know
it just sags on that face i know knows
to hold it up and
you remember the
the viral video um because it kind of
reminded me of that too because it sags
on your face remember the pants on the
ground the
do you remember that video the pants on
the ground i don't know
pants on the ground and pants on the
ground i don't know some some guys i
mean i ran about pants sagging and pants
on the ground was it like like
yeah someone made a remix and it went it
went like viral and um uh they remind
the droop
yeah
maybe maybe there should be a song to
this commercial i i think we'll have to
put this in the rotation though
yeah so you know
absolutely absolutely so so uh everyone
uh see if you can catch when we if we
play
the droop
the i love the the name of the droop
because we have the pardon blanket
everyone likes the bar that's one of my
favorites the pardon blanket uh
especially right now with the president
you did you see these clips of grandpa
poopy pants pretending to be the
president acting like he's gonna pardon
act like no i i missed this one this is
what happens when you i'm on the west
coast so i don't get that you know i
wake up and i'm i'm playing catch up to
all this now here you go here's here's
newsmax we watched it just a minute ago
but
america's number one news network yeah i
would absolutely
give them a pardon the punishment things
don't work out fairly punishments are
out of proportion to the crime out of
proportion like 20 times out of
proportion oh he sounds really scared
about what his punishment is going to be
didn't he
yeah why yeah why why why is he so uh i
don't know
he's a little he's a little scared it
seems like it just seems a little odd to
me that somebody would
try to
pardon blanket pardon everyone blanket
pardon blanket or blind what's the yeah
it's you know just give everyone a part
and blanket to go home with yeah right
right well um the funny thing is is that
he thinks he can do this like right now
like he's saying it as if he's going to
sign this is that like the executive
privilege thing like right he's still
claiming he's got it but it's like
you're not in office anymore right dude
you don't have the pardon power right
that's not a thing you get and it's not
a thing you're gonna get right i mean i
don't think you understand how this
works so um speaking of elections and
speaking how this works and making sure
that uh republicans don't destroy
everything so we can stay pissed and go
[ __ ] vote
um that way we can save our democracy
david pepper post this video about an
hour ago
he says new whiteboard in ohio they want
to rig the court so they can rig
elections and they just come out and
admit it of course they do to the court
of all places why
because here and elsewhere rigged state
houses are the key to everything else
they do advice sit down before you watch
this um so he does a pretty good job of
explaining this here it's a couple
minutes long
but i do want to play it because i think
people need to understand that it's just
not the united states house of
representatives and the united states
senate that we have to protect here like
these down ballot races are super
important and these state house races
are super important and and it's it's
it's the clock is ticking here but we
have to stay pissed we have to go
[ __ ] vote and and
he's giving you a little bit of advice
here but let's listen to what he has to
say when i titled my book laboratories
of autocracy i was not exaggerating and
i was not trying to be cute it's exactly
how they're behaving and you're seeing
this exploding right now around the
country whether it's this disturbing
wave of book bans and history censorship
whether it's attacks on the conduct of
elections themselves and we've seen this
uh book ban stuff um you know uh right
we're telling you they're gonna start
burning books soon
well yeah absolutely well i mean these
right-wingers are trying to use like a
uh the old left-wing arguments of well
there's an n-word in this book so the
book must be bad right right forget the
context of why it's in there and the
story well not even that it's it's books
that are like oh
this is sexualizing something it's like
it's not sexualizing it it's you
thinking that it is sexualizing right
like oh god forbid it's a same-sex
relationship
banned and it's like god forbid it's
something you know uh
someone talking about their experience
of being
uh
uh
black or indigenous or hispanic or gay
or lesbian or whatever it is you know or
you know uh
and it's like oh it's a story it's it's
a it's a story or you know fiction or
non-fiction telling
that experience and they go nope
can't have it and the thing is
primarily targeted
around
um
people
who are women
uh marginalized communities those are
the voices that are getting suppressed
these are the only people mainly the
only people who are talking about these
perspectives and these experiences and
these are the ones that are getting
you know
the
the the banning that's happening to them
so well
right and and when you see that to kill
a mockingbird specifically
like
i mean
again the book is much deeper than just
the racial issues right there's a lot
going on in that book there's a lot of
narrative in that book but to to you
know it's the same thing um when when
folks wanted to ban the adventures of
huckleberry finn because the n word is
in that book a lot
a lot it's in that book but if you
actually read the book you'd understand
why it's in there and why the context of
showing you why it's so dumb that that
word even exists towards black people
right like like if you read the book and
you read the context and that's the
problem here
i think is that people aren't willing to
like even go google it to [ __ ] read
the synopsis of the book like we're in
such a place in society that if it's not
on a [ __ ] facebook meme it's not
worth knowing right like how in the [ __ ]
did we get in a situation where the
ivermectin institute
um the facebook groups is is way more
truth than what any kind of real context
of history could tell you inside of a
book especially a piece of literature
like to kill a mockingbird like i mean i
i can't remember exactly what grade i
was in uh when it was required reading
in our school but i do believe i was in
junior high it was the same
i believe sixth seventh grade in that
time maybe even eighth grade and we also
read lord of the flies right uh which is
it yeah i don't is that another one
that's been banned well i mean i'm sure
it won't take long i i was trying to say
this yesterday i know you were busy
yesterday and couldn't make it on the
show but yesterday i was trying to say
you know everyone was uh going crazy
because tom brady was retiring i'm like
look you you guys
if you're not gonna [ __ ] wake up and
realize that it doesn't matter about tom
brady like yeah you like him yeah you
don't whatever you might have your
opinions but here's the thing
if you don't [ __ ] wake up to this
fascism and realize that this stuff's at
the front door you're not gonna have an
nfl you're not gonna have an mba right
you're not gonna let these black dudes
play professional sports
what don't you understand they're gonna
tear down everything your churches your
communities your schools it's all gonna
be [ __ ] gone you're not gonna have to
wonder whose house you're gonna watch
the super bowl at there won't be one so
i get that that you know the super bowl
is like super [ __ ] important but
really
if you want the super bowl
you should take a few minutes to pay
attention to [ __ ]
of why you have the super bowl right why
it's a thing that exists in this country
why we can be entertained by athletes
playing a sport and and the best
athletes playing a sport regardless
regardless of their skin color their
nationality their religion
uh even sometimes their [ __ ] criminal
history which is you know a whole other
argument but the point is is that if you
want these things if you want this this
way of life this american way of life
you're gonna have to start paying
attention to just a few more things
other than who's retiring from football
let's play the rest of this because he
does break down what they're trying to
do the fascism creeping into the state
houses
it's just non-stop and it's getting
worse and i try to explain but one
reason the prime reason it's so bad is
we're essentially dealing with an entire
generation of majorities in these state
houses where almost every member has
risen to power without democracy their
elections have always been rigged their
entire career they don't know what a
real election looks like and they're
scared of real elections and real
democracy so they'll do everything they
can to suppress democracy to keep
themselves in power and that's why the
the in the end of the day the key to
their whole system is rig state house
elections we like to focus on
congressional gerrymandering but the key
to the non-stop attack on democracy goes
back to lack of accountability lack of
democracy in state houses they know that
and that's why the biggest fight you'll
see is to re-rig state house districts
and that's what we're seeing in ohio
right now and it's instructive so i'll
walk through it so round one of their
districting process they literally drew
a ridiculous unconstitutional map but
they also told the supreme court of ohio
we don't need to follow the constitution
as you'd expect that didn't go very well
it was struck down right so so he's
going through their plan here and like
this is intentional
like what he's saying is like there
there's none of this that they didn't
plan on it happening the way it happened
right
as he said he knows it's
unconstitutional they know the courts
are going to strike this down so then
listen to what he says round two
is
taking a very interesting turn first
they drew another ridiculous map as i
explained the prior whiteboard but they
also said to the court we're running out
of time
we propose if you don't fix this in the
next week or so that we that you stay
the entire case until after the coming
election they literally are proposing to
have an election on a map that is rigged
uh and then go back and look at the map
so you see what you see what he's saying
there uh because i i
would love to have uh dave pepper on um
to ask him about this because i think
it's very important because i think what
he's saying here is that their intention
was to torch the case right so you go in
you torch the case the court the court
says [ __ ] you you can't do this this map
is [ __ ] rigged and then they're like
oh well oh my god well we have to do
this we have to get this done you know
so so what they did was is by creating
this map that they knew wasn't going to
get approved they create this crisis
right they're always these crisis this
fake crisis [ __ ] they developed this
through through channels just the same
way as they did with sb8 in texas
the same [ __ ] thing where they're
going to take away the liberty of
people who have uteruses in texas they
act like it's some kind of [ __ ] uh
urgent thing that they have to do we
have to take care of this it's a big
crisis this is what they always do the
same way with voter ids and
other voter suppression laws they create
this crisis and then they have to fix it
and what they what it actually means is
fix it up so they win so let's let's
listen ridiculous right what's worse
than even that because what they're
really playing here is a game of trying
to rig the court the chief justice who
was part of the 4-3 majority struck down
the map
hits her age limit this year has to
retire they have a candidate running to
replace her their game is clearly to
replace that with with a justice who
they will vote for them the governor
who's breaking the map would appoint
that replacement his son is also in the
court not refusing himself so their goal
is to get themselves a majority they
would then uphold the map they're trying
to rig a court to rig the elections
that's how power hungry these people are
and we know that for sure that they're
that power hungry uh
let's see i'm gonna give david credit
great video i forget someone retweeted
that's how i that's how i found it um i
don't even know if i'm i'm pretty sure
i'm following david here we're gonna
check here um get him on the show anyone
reach out yeah reach out to him yeah i
am following david and david if you're
listening if you're listening come on
the show and talk about this issue we
will amplify your voice to our audience
if that if that works for you now let's
see
um yeah eugene says david would be a
great guest oh you misspelled that's
okay yeah i type i type fast dude no no
big deal eugene now eugene's here with
us uh let's see what else we got here um
uh uh uh veteran yoda says gotta
gotta gabe shout out oh yeah yeah you
made yoda's day maybe you know this day
so
um you know gabe gives the shout outs
and and they have the what about me
so so gabe um we're working on getting
this at in the background here we're
trying yeah if i seem to if i seem
distracted to anyone i i apologize i am
not i'm focused on getting you guys
something that i think you're gonna like
yeah so um let's let's talk about that
why you're doing that i'll explain a
little bit so actually let me pull let
me pull something up here yeah set the
stage set the set to set the stage as
they say
um because you guys know there's a lot
of stuart rhodes news going on today
and we've been talking about uh that we
have a very special interview here this
week now let me just pull up scott's
report here
you guys know this morning uh well last
night actually um scott says his defense
lawyers told stewart rhodes that they
were gonna have a zoom call today with
the january sixth select committee of
course this is the picture the
infamous picture here of stuart rhodes
and everyone always anytime i post
anything like retweet something or
anything i always have this situation
where people are like
oh he shot his eye out as an instructor
why does he wear the eye patch did he
really shoot himself in the face and
you know all this kind of stuff right
well gabe i hear
that we may have that story is that is
that fair to say yep yep just give me
that just give me a minute but yes we do
have that story we have about almost an
hour and a half of that story i mean
well
we have
several minutes of that story of an hour
and a half of a longer story right right
so we do have an interview um that we
did
with stuart
rhodes estranged wife soon to be ex-wife
and his son um we recorded this several
days ago we've been trying to get it
edited um we're trying to seek
distribution as well i guess you could
say that's fair enough to say yeah yeah
um so that way this thing could get
amplified um because
she tells the actual story yeah of
there's a lot of a lot of details and
and not only not only the story like
she tells the story not only like
how he shot himself right because
everyone keeps saying he's a uh an
instructor and all like right right
which is true right he did teach he was
a gun instructor at some point right at
some point right and people have seen
like videos of him like uh you know
several years ago where he doesn't have
the eye patch right and there's also a
story that she tells that is behind the
actual eyepatch well what we don't see
behind the eye patch right
yeah she has a very very detailed story
about about that yeah as well uh
yeah a lot of a lot of details that i
don't think anyone else has no no not at
this point and i'm hoping that we can
air this either
um tomorrow
or we can air it
um maybe friday i'm i'm hoping we can
get it tomorrow on the show we're really
close um we're working with um some
folks again to distribute the story so
we can amplify it um just because some
of the stuff is so important of course
everyone wants to know
about you know how he came to not have
his eye and how he has the eye patch
which is a good story but also
um
anne says
interesting that'll be juicy ah well a
juicy is a word
[Laughter]
juicy
juicy is a word that
it is certainly a word that can be used
to describe and i believe
we
are
i feel like i'm about to be like jeff
goldman we
are
uh just uh ready to go
i don't know i don't know why first
nation you should you should you know
you don't do that many impersonations
just with the voice you have wigs you
have the costumes and makeup
you know you don't just do the voices a
lot
you should bring you should bring him on
you know yeah he's so quirky you know
appointments i like apartments apart you
know he's got
all right are you are you are you uh
pretty close there it's it's up so what
we're what we're going to do is we're
going to play a quick video clip
of um
play a quick video clip
oh boy oh boy here we go of the it's
uploading oh this is exciting of the uh
this is almost like uh you know um
that that that uh
what was the guy shane vaughn um
fantasizing about the uh the dogs in the
yard and you get this you get this sense
of of anxiety um but we are going to
again we'll probably air this interview
in its entirety during the podcast
either
tomorrow
or possibly uh friday we're again we're
still working on that
looks like we have the
the video here let me go ahead and uh
should we go ahead and play the video oh
there it's gone oh wait hold on wait
sorry
no no it's there
over here yeah yeah
yeah okay well upload it upload it on
the uh the clips here okay
yeah it'll play all right all right all
right
these producers i tell you you know it's
like i'm trying to do it come on they
don't know how to turn they're trying to
entertain the people and answer the
questions and
um you know what
why you're doing that let me let me see
if i can
let me see if i can find
why we're waiting on this clip
let's see here
well uh
oh
the silence
yeah i know well you know usually
there's not silence on my show
uh here here we go here here's here's
the clip here's the clip are we ready
yeah all right let's go ahead and let's
go and play the clip for the audience
and then we'll talk about it on the
other side and we also have
by the way we i don't i want everyone to
know here soon we're going to bring
natalie james on here in just a few
minutes now it looks like she's joined
us in the green room are you ready over
there natalie
great okay so so we're going to play the
clip we'll talk about this interview and
then we'll bring natalie on let's play
the clip now which brings me to one
thing that everyone wants to know
because this is the story that everyone
wants to hear
um stuart where's an eye patch we've
seen it in the in the uh
in the mug shots
and in the tunnel videos like we said
earlier the spider whole
uh tactical whole he did not have an eye
patch so there is a story going around
that he shot himself in the eye um i
don't know how that is what it is do you
guys know the story and can you tell us
the story of how stuart seemed to have
an eye patch all right this is three
stories there is the event
okay and the facts that happened
and there's also this story he told
there's
which is mostly lie
there's
also
what i believe actually happened and it
took me 20 years to piece it together
and then
there's the second event which is why he
stopped wearing a prosthetic eye
um i guess i'll start with him shooting
himself in the face
[Laughter]
you'll start by
shooting himself in the face
it really is a great interview because
um not only not only does does natalie
join us but his son stewart's son
student and excuse me tasha tasha i got
natalie here i got tasha going yeah
tasha
uh
joins us but also dakota his son and he
talks a lot about um
the the militia part of the oath keepers
and like how all that came to be he
explains some of the stuff about the
bundy ranch and then also really the
most important part about the interview
to me i mean obviously everyone wants to
know about him shooting himself in the
face in the eye patch but don't you
think that one of the most important
things
was not only the way that they described
what kind of person stuart rhodes is but
really dive into like what what his
motivations were of why the oak keepers
and he used the oath keepers to do what
they did on january 6 and probably why
he's charged with uh conspiracy to
commit sedition don't you think that's
like the the really that like that's the
[ __ ] everyone needs to hear yeah yeah
there's uh there is a lot going on
uh that both dakota and tasha leia
because dakota has a lot of information
because he was there you know um
in in like the development of
uh uh or really just like the way that
stewart ended up like how he kind of
became who he was and how everything
brought up like he's got inside
information that he was able to reveal
to us i mean as well as tasha but but
dakota definitely has more of the
militia um right because he was there
with with stuart like as it was
happening and he would go to these
events um the other thing that i found
significant is when dakota starts uh
describing some of those uh military
type operations that they were using or
they thought they were going to use
during january 6. um that's that's an
important part of the interview too but
more than anything too um tasha's story
about who stewart is what kind of person
he is um and how the oath keepers
because they were there the whole time
that this oath keeper thing was
happening right like um from the very
beginning they were there they
experienced it with him um good batter
and different a lot of bad and
indifferent um to be quite honest with
you in an interview and i i don't know
how long did the interview end up being
just over an hour
yeah it's like uh
an hour or 15 hours okay i want to say
so what we'll do what we'll do for the
audience is we will try to figure out
exactly when we're going to air there's
either tomorrow or friday um if it's
friday you know we do the bone end of
the week so we'll probably air it in the
first hour on friday if we do friday um
tomorrow i'm not sure exactly what that
looks like but maybe we'll do tomorrow
in the first or second hour if we get it
but we will announce we will announce
this um do you want to stick around with
me and talk to natalie or do you have
time okay let's let's just let's go to a
break and when we come back we'll bring
natalie um she's a candidate a
democratic candidate for the u.s senate
in the state of arkansas
and i wanted her to come on because she
explains uh act blue in a certain way
that i wanted to get her take on so stay
right there we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble mag
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that i'm struggling with i
chose babel mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for hanging with a break we're
gonna bring in natalie james
in just a few minutes
[Music]
she's
one of the democratic candidates for the
us senate in arkansas
she has a certain way of explaining act
blue that i liked uh how she explained
it so i wanted to get her take here and
then we'll we'll cut it out and we'll
post it up on youtube so that way
everyone can go go take a look at it um
so don't don't forget to subscribe to
the youtube channel that way you can see
all those clips and also you don't want
to miss this interview that we're
talking about with stuart rhodes
estranged ex-wife our future ex-wife
yeah and and his son tasha and dakota um
adams as they are as they are referred
to now they did change their names they
talk about that in the interview as well
so don't miss that we're hoping to
announce that this afternoon uh a time
whether it be thursday or friday again
we're working with some partners to to
get this distributed so that way we can
get it out to the masses but right now i
want to bring in i want to bring in a
democratic
uh candidate
for the senate seat in the state of
arkansas uh
natalie james natalie how are you i am
good how are you doing oh we are doing
fantastic we're doing fantastic i you
know um we we we've talked a few times
and you go in twitter spaces i've been
going to these twitter spaces
yes yes and and i see you in there all
the time um i feel like i almost know
you it you know from the interwebs
um and we did we did a sound test the
other day to make sure we were good but
you you did something the other day you
explained act blue and you talked about
act blue because a lot of democrats out
there and and i mean people who are
donating to democratic campaigns
they're they get they get kind of
confused about like donating to act blue
what does that mean who does it go to
and you did such a good job explaining i
really wanted you to come on the show
and give us that perspective um because
i think a lot of people do you think
that maybe is their hesitancy sometimes
because they don't know what act blue is
that and they don't know where it's
going and what it's for a lot of times
what i'm seeing people are like oh you
must have a lot of money to run no i'm
speaking your voice this is our voice so
it's us doing this together it's not
just me doing this i'm running to better
represent you and to make sure that you
have a voice so being a good citizen
also comes from voting and yes donating
to candidates that are going to speak
for you
right because that's important because
it's not just like money for like
television commercials like you guys
have to make sure that you got water and
food transportation um for some of your
your door knockers the people who are
helping canvas um all that stuff matters
and that's like what you need some of
that money for whether it's you or
another campaign
but explain that act blue because that
that is on a tag because there's act
blue and then there's the republican one
now i i think i feel like republicans
have always understood that the voters
in this country have understood how to
donate and why to donate all that kind
of stuff for years but explain to us
that act blue what it means how it goes
to a candidate i mean you can use
yourself for another candidate as an
example so all right
so with ag blue what at blue is is this
wonderful little platform app it's a
web-based can be used on your cell phone
and it's how you donate directly to a
candidate it's secure it protects your
information and it gives us the
availability to see where our money is
actually coming from who it's coming
from so we can send thank you notes and
everything else but that money is so
important because candidates like me
need it for door knocking pamphlets
things to hand out flyers make sure we
have gas to get to the different events
and get around and actually door knock
it's also extremely important so that
we're able to make sure we're amplifying
our voice in your voice so like we use
it for post-it stamps we use the
donations to pay our campaign staff we
use it to make sure that we're just
running the behind-the-scenes back
office those websites aren't free your
um emails going out that's not free
making sure the campaign has staff
phones has staff which is important
because all those correspondence and
emails that you see coming out those are
done by somebody and people are to be
paid for their work and i believe in
making sure people are paid for their
work do do and rightly so so the
importance of donating directly to act
blue and not donating to i mean there's
nothing wrong with donating to the dnc
and all of the alphabets they are
amazing they do great for the candidates
but they do the support after primaries
after they feel that that candidate is
ready and worthy the what gets us on the
map is when you make an act blue
donation and those blue donations equal
up to over a hundred thousand that lets
us know that we're a viable candidate
because it's done by you and for you as
a grassroots it's your voice so it's
another way of you just being heard
donating to act blue at blue is
so so i was to ask you because i i that
the touching back on the the alphabet
and them supporting you because i think
that's important to people they think oh
well you're you're a democrat you're
running for senate the dnc must be
giving you all kinds of money natalie
and what they don't understand is you're
running a primary right so the dnc isn't
going to pick and choose at this point
who they're going to support and give
money
what they're doing is seeing how you
raise money right so they're seeing how
you're raising money so does the act
blue when they go to natalie james of
zach blue right or or any other
candidate and they donate to that
candidate zach blue does it go directly
to the candidate does it go to the dnc
how does that work it goes directly to
the candidate it skips the dnc they do
their own stuff like they raised 100
million dollars this last quarter which
is not a bad thing that's a good thing
no it's not it's a great thing because
they're able to spread it out all right
hopefully spread out all over the united
states but when you have a candidate
that aligns with the issues that align
with you you want to donate directly to
them so that way you can continue to
feel their campaign so that they can be
a voice of reason a lot of times
candidates like me or candidates are
left behind and aren't heard from it's
because they don't have the donations
and the support to be able to push them
out as much as they need to get out and
be able to have their voices be heard so
at blue is a very very instrumental tool
for candidates to make sure that we are
getting out there we have the support
that we need and you have the support
that you need when you want to go to
washington when you want state
legislation when you're just running for
any office at blue is an amazing amazing
tool that goes directly to the candidate
so the candidate can use it for other
office things that are needed such as
stamps those cards
saying thank you being able to pick up
the phone bottles of water i mean
essentials exactly right you know
gatorade the normal right right right
because people are working their asses
off they need a drink or two here and
there and there so exactly
so the other the other thing that you
explained in the spaces about the act
blue was not just that it goes directly
to the candidates so i think people out
there can rest assured that it's a safe
way a secure way to give to a candidate
that you have found that you like that
you want to support rather despite what
republicans may claim right about you
know yes right exactly republicans
definitely have it like a
targeted disinformation campaign and you
saw it throughout 2020 and 2021 which
was you know don't trust act blue it is
money's going here right despite the
fact that their platform when red
is locking people into recurring
donations and caused trump to have to
return all of the fraudulent charges
essentially is what was done so
right well one of the largest credit
card frauds in history like right like
literally in history but we could but we
can rest assure that act blue
act blue is is completely secure it is
going to the candidate that you're
giving through through their act blue
yes now explain explain though because
you you did a really good job of
explaining this because i think this is
another thing that that people donating
to democratic campaigns fail to
recognize that money can't go up it goes
down right
um so explain how that works when they
give to um a governor's race or state
legislators race or a senate race like
yours explain how that works all right
so
yes at blue is secure yes goes directly
to us i go pick up my own mailbox checks
and donate it and put it into my actual
campaign account myself so it lets me
know and it makes me extremely happy
that we have support but the best thing
about act blue and what we're able to do
and what we're able to do with your
donations is when you find a candidate
that's in a congressional race they can
do it and send money down to the
constitutional races they can send it
down ticket so it's important when you
have top of the ticket candidates that
you support to support them heavily
because guess what you have a jp you
have a quorum court you have a city
director you have a school board
somebody that's running might not have
the following fee might need a little
help we're able to transfer those fees
to them to make sure that they have the
support that they need so
that is the responsibility of top of the
ticket not many people
realize that and while we go to the top
of the ticket because that's what the
federal government is supposed to do
we're supposed to help be the voice and
amplify the voice of the people and so
agblue allows us to do that but you have
to donate to those top of the ticket
actual um
actual holders which is important such
as your federal races such as your
senate race u.s senate race such as your
congressional office such as your
district offices and things like that
that way we're able to help out our
state constituents who are running for
legislator who are running for state
senate who are running for house senate
excuse me our your local house and
everything else that's what makes it so
important so we can have a very strong
ticket because if the top can't support
the middle and the bottom
we won't have a foundation and we're not
going to have a strong ticket so we want
to make sure that we have an extremely
strong ticket and we're able to allocate
funds where they need to go because it's
not the responsibility of the party it's
not the responsibility of the dnc it is
the responsibility of the people and
those running for the highest office
that's going to be your voice the united
states senate is the highest office that
there is there are a hundred people that
make decisions that directly affect you
policy and your future so you want to
make sure that you're donating to those
people and that they are representing
your voice appropriately and the best
way to do that again i know we keep
harping on donations
it is to donate because we do so much
more than just going to our campaign it
feeds the campaign for you a piece of
campaign for the ticket
well and and i think that's a good a
fantastic point that you can help those
down ballot races because um if you got
a few minutes i'd like to talk to you
about the ticket in arkansas but i'd
also i'd also like to talk to you about
um a little bit because you are a black
woman and i i know that you will have
opinions about the supreme court pick
and what the news is and all this
[ __ ] surrounding that joe biden
can't make the pick that he wants even
though he promised to make it because
that scotus nominee needs to look like
america and i believe you look like
america and i believe america that
scotus needs to look more like you i i
truly believe that and and i said
yesterday
i'm not just for joe biden picking one
black woman i think he should expand in
court and pick three or four black women
and put them on the court now that would
start to fix what the problems that we
have so the first thing i want to the
first thing i want to ask is about your
ticket in arkansas and then we'll get to
the supreme court uh pick
so tell us a little bit because i know
you guys got a really diverse really
strong ticket for the democrats down in
arkansas so anyone watching tell us
about that so they can maybe pay
attention more to that ticket down there
in arkansas okay arkansas we are blessed
to have one of the most amazing diverse
tickets that we've ever ever seen in
history before you guys have the first
opportunity to elect the first black
woman to the united states senate out of
arkansas there are currently no black
women sitting in the senate which is
scary we know what magic black women are
able to bring and we know what the
nation is needing what the nation is
wanting so we want to make sure that we
amplify those voices we have in our
gubernatorial rights excuse me i'm
skipping i forgot my congressional
people our ticket is so diverse so we
have monty hodges running for
congressional district
he's running for congressional district
one that is in northeast arkansas he's
been in legislation state legislation
for over 11 to 14 years i can't remember
the number exactly but he is amazing a
black man for the first time we have a
black man running for congressional
office for congressional district four
excuse me one
then for congressional district two we
have dr quintessa hathaway we have a
black woman this is the second time
we've had a black woman run for this
office and hopefully this time we get it
then we have congressional district
three lauren mallett hayes my dear
friend
she is a woman working mother nurse
everything on the front lines exactly
what we need to have real life
experiences here representing all of our
kansans in all of the united states then
we have congressional district 4 that's
coming up we still have a couple people
who are wanting to get in the race but
again that is a great great great start
just at the top of the ticket in the
congressional seats because currently
those seats are set by six congressional
republican members and they are
they're not indicative of us they have
not had to have the same the qualms
issues bankruptcy repossession
um
worried about how they're going to pay
rent worried about how they're going to
pay mortgage worried about how they're
going to take care of their children's
education worried about their children
and what's going on in public school
because their children aren't in public
school then private school because
they're afforded whatever luxuries that
they're afforded to and hand down so
when you have somebody that is not
that has not had to experience life the
way that most arkansans have had to
experience life they do not think
correctly and correlate with what's
going on with us currently none of them
can be related to majority of arkansans
or americans then for our district for
our ticket what we have is our
gubernatorial race
we have an amazing slate of candidates
we have james russell we have anthony dr
anthony blind we have dr chris jones we
have um supah mays she's aapi she's a um
island pacificer that came over here
she's amazing as well we have a rocket
scientist do you hear me a rock
yes
a real one a real one
turns out they're just a rocket model
builder
a cosplay there we go right right right
but we have a real one in arkansas that
yeah that is what seat is the rocket
scientist running for governor he is
running for governor against sarah
huckabee now i'm i don't know about
y'all but sarah didn't do a good job in
washington and compared to a rocket
scientist i don't think it's rocket
science for me to figure out
i would rather have somebody that knows
exactly what they're doing trusted by
nasa trusted by literally the space
stars
i would rather have that type of voice
than any other especially sarah huckabee
which is what the republicans are
offering us they have a great diverse
ticket too for them they have a bunch of
women
right
that's one step
yeah right
at least they're at least they're there
at least they're there so speaking
speaking of diversity in women um of
course this week we know that um justice
breyer is is officially going to retire
um it seems like joe biden's going to
make his pick during the campaign joe
biden promised um
made promises that he that he would
really heavily consider and probably
more than likely pick a black woman um
if a skoda seat would come up um i think
it's a fantastic choice number one
because we've never had a black woman on
the court before i believe that that
black woman being some of the most
educated um
people in the country i i don't know
exactly what the percentages is but
like 60 some percent of all master's
degrees uh 67 percent of all doctorates
um and bachelor's degrees are black
women what's that small business yeah
small businesses
and and so
the smartest the smartest most educated
group of people in this country more
more than qualified what i find funny
about it is that they're like oh you're
just picking her because she's black i'm
like do you have any idea how many
how many black women that are qualified
to be on the supreme court like like the
list is probably so long that joe biden
is gonna have to take weeks and weeks
and weeks just to figure out if the top
tier that he had already really
that he had in his mind to nominate if
there's not someone else to stick in
that spot and really there's so many
qualified black women to be on the
supreme court that no one even knows who
he's gonna pick like they're making
assumptions exactly but normally
normally you're like oh well there's
gonna be this guy who's a sweaty white
ball sack and that is exactly who
they're gonna pick and they know exactly
who they're gonna pick right there's so
many qualified black women to be on this
court that no one is even i don't i
don't think no one's gonna guess exactly
right but they're just all over the map
so tell us your opinion because i know
you probably have a an opinion on this
a very strong opinion i mean if we have
somebody who ran for office and said
that they promised they're going to
build a wall and didn't do it then i
think we should be able to have somebody
say i promise to elect a black woman or
nominate a black woman to the supreme
court keep in mind he's not the first um
first president to do it right right to
promise to make the promise right
exactly at least we know he's going to
follow through because that wall is
still not finished down there right we
like to bring up so much if we're going
to talk about those empty promises talk
about the empty promises that were
already cast before with that previous
whatever we guys want to call 45 we're
going to say
exactly
that cancerous growth that's what i'm
going to call them the cancerous growth
because that's what he's done he's
infected america with the cancer of hate
and spreading that type of division and
talk about identity politics right no
we're electing the most qualified and
the most qualified on that list happen
to be a strong list of black women right
that's not our fault don't penalize us
because those are the most qualified
candidates at the time and they're
scared i mean that's what it is right
they're afraid you've got you know ted
cruz foot in the mouth saying the other
day he's like oh how can you know we
elect some women or a a woman a black
woman to be on the on uh on the bench
and it's like okay well i guess we're
gonna
yeah he said i think he said insulting
was actually right yeah yeah
he was insulted
by his allowing him to kiss up to
somebody who talked about his wife let's
just talk about that
right exactly
who could you possibly be talking about
yeah it's like insulted let's talk about
you know what's coming up on
right now
right we're coming up on the one year
anniversary of cancun cruz going down to
mexico on behalf of his daughters coming
in and we still have not fixed the grid
right and well let's talk about that to
be upgraded and offended like on behalf
of all texans yo right right that's
insulting right exactly so let's not
talk about what's insulting offending or
anything else because him he's just an
egregious insult on the world yeah so
he's an embarrassment if there's one
thing i will say is the podcast uh
he sits in an armchair you know
uh and i really are you're talking about
ted cruz's yeah
he's got his uh
you know whatever he is
yeah
and i'm just like oh you know he's just
an armchair senator right like that's
all he he's just that's yes
he's you know he thinks he's an expert
on something
exactly you know he put out a list this
morning speaking of that [ __ ] he put out
a list this morning on twitter about the
uh how to be prepared for winner and
never is like check
check for your check for your your
cancun plane tickets like all local
travel agents he stopped the child tax
credit which would enable people to be
able to be prepared for that that's
right people who are which is inflation
protection by the way the child tax
credit is inflation protection that's
that and and now i believe that we
should actually and and i don't know
what your your view is and i'm sure i i
could guess pretty quick clearly but my
view is is that we should actually
include inflation and protection to all
americans retired um you know working
families whether they have children or
not we should we should provide
inflation protection because of what we
went through with the the coronavirus
and the pandemic and how the last
[ __ ] idiot mismanaged it so badly
that you know we're trying to get our
way out of this economy and inflation is
happening because it's eating up so fast
because there's so much demand um
but back to the back to the the skoda's
pick the thing
the thing that makes me uh is i don't i
don't know if it's annoyed or laugh
is is when they say you're making it all
about race and like look
black women are black black women are
black like that like
what how how the hell yeah right it's
always been the same normal status quo
it has always been that and now you're
upset that it's going to change a little
bit and it makes you uncomfortable guess
what you'll be okay they're a little
scared they're a little terrified
they're people with color in the world
you will be okay that's right i'm not
gonna bite you we're not gonna hurt you
we're gonna do what's in the best
interest of you because we are here with
you so we're going to always make sure
we're taking care of you because
inherently it takes care of us
regardless of how well you don't take
care of yourself with ivermectin and now
with the wormwood and other things like
that we're still going to take care of
you because that's what you deserve
because you are an american and you have
your freedom of rights and speech and
everything else but
allow us to do our job and allow us to
make this nation back whole again where
it needs to be it's a lot put on our
shoulders and yes we are extremely tired
of having to come in and fix the same
messes that are being messed up but this
time let us fix it so we don't have to
mess it up again
right natalie i really appreciate you
coming on and you're at the i i love
your your the way you talk and um how
you go after these these these these
folks i guess we'll i you know i i'll
i'll be nice and call them folks today
i i really do appreciate you coming
you're gonna have to come back on uh
we'll have to find um more times to have
you on i do appreciate you joining us
thank you very much we'll talk to you
very very soon yes i appreciate you now
i'm getting ready to hop on these oh one
more thing before we go where do people
go find your campaign it is james for
arkansas.com yes people powered you guys
are paying for that that's why that
website is still there up and running so
james for arkansas.com you can check me
out on twitter i'm very active on
twitter at james4ar you can check me out
on instagram i'm very active on there
you can check me out at james for
arkansas on tick tock yes i have a tick
tock ticky tocks gabe likes to ticky
talk i gotta take that down too shaky
ducky quack quack on ticket
and then of course facebook and i'm
getting better at being active on there
but yes i greatly greatly enjoyed this i
can't wait to do it again and reach more
people because this is what it is it's
going to take us having these
uncomfortable conversations and making
them comfortable and normal so that we
can address the issues and right the
wrongs and we can grow do this democracy
thing right like actually governments
who would want to do democracy inside of
a democracy you know hey i don't know
somebody that like what's his name our
favorite person alexander hamilton maybe
you know when they kind of wrote this
constitution like
right right they wanted to do the
democracy thing
that's right that's right well thank you
for joining us natalie we'll talk to you
very very very soon thank you have a
good one
hard work out there hard work we'll see
you soon bye-bye thank you
vet fantastic fantastic great awesome
we got to have her back on way way
every week maybe um she does a great job
of going after ted cruz i like that i i
would love to hear her go after tom
gotten i mean that's
i was i wanted
is she going after his seat or the other
guy's seat so it is it is tom cotton's
seat um okay
because there's john boozman is it
boozman is it boo it's bluesman it's
boozman that that's yeah it's boozman
yeah yeah that's that's coming i can't
verify but uh but yeah i i want her i
want her to take on yeah of course you
know her opponent too who the general
election but i love right i love i love
to hear natalie you know uh tie up tom
cotton and drag him through the mud that
would be fantastic so maybe maybe maybe
next week we'll uh because tom cotton is
always doing something stupid in the
news like this guy
he was saying something dumb yesterday i
don't know what the hell was he saying
yesterday he was trending yesterday
because he said [ __ ] something dumb
oh yeah i would i would uh yeah because
she's going out it's uh it's john
boozman's seat that is up for right
re-election so if she can uh if she can
nab that seat that would be great
you know yes i'm pushing for and
obviously to have you know some some
sense of balance and reality and
intelligence uh i mean even from the
small conversation i had with her it's
like yeah she cares about the american
people as opposed to these other
folks right
yeah [ __ ] him he's [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
that's that's what i have to say yeah
you know so but uh yeah but so thanks
natalie for joining us um so uh let's
see what else we got here
okay um
we're gonna go back to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends here i think
oh look at here
speaking of speaking are you ready kids
are you ready for the interview all
right
that's the uh i mean that's it that's
immediately what i saw happen
or it came to mind like when the news
dropped that like initially a couple
weeks ago i like i would took a nap
because i was like so tired and then i
woke up from that nap and this new set
dropped and the mug shot had come out
and then i was like oh the first thing i
see right here is spongebob and i was
like are you ready kids oh that that was
the uh that was the you you put out a uh
i recreated the spongebob uh uh frame
yeah yeah came with that i put him on
the yeah right right see i don't i don't
watch spongebob so explain explain the
uh is it it's basically uh it's like
it's
well yeah it there's the krusty krab
right down in bikini bottom but in the
beginning of the show it's a pirate with
the parrot on his shoulder and he's
asking he's like are you ready kids and
then it goes uh oh okay and then and
then the theme song starts and it goes
down yeah that's bob's square pants
exactly that's exactly uh but you
that's the only time you ever see the
spon or that's the only time you ever
see the the pirate because it's just a
painting on the wall
and then it goes down to bikini bottom
and it does the whole intro and stuff
like that but i got you i got you yeah
yeah it was iconic and people know mj
says gabe is so talented oh thank you so
much the audience loves gaming and
mayo's here hey mayor
um yoda said let's go broadband i like
that one let's go broadband hell yeah oh
that's funny that's funny did you see
the uh i showed earlier the whoopi
goldberg
story but did you see
this uh and i think i think maybe you
commented on it uh because it was my
comment like
yesterday the right wingers were like oh
whoopi goldberg she's a racist she's a
racist i'm like really you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i had
yeah yeah i had seen this photo before
from florida and i
i like quickly passed over it's one of
those things where it's like you can
have the beginning the ending of the
word and jumble the middle and you would
still understand that's what it's yeah
that's what it says right but then i saw
it again when you sent it to me and i go
they
misspelled brandon there's no d in there
right b-r-a-n-o-n
which also let's just point out they say
that they're the master race
this master race who can't [ __ ] spell
they're all [ __ ] idiots yes i know
that obviously you know these nazis
neo-nazis are terrible people and i
agree they're [ __ ] the worst of the
worst but
they also claim that they are the
perfect race
get the [ __ ] out of here well number one
is this like a bed sheet yeah i don't
know it's probably it's probably a sheet
that they put up and they might [ __ ]
just took back home right no that is a
that is a piece of fabric that they are
definitely going to take back home and
sleep and wrap themselves in like it was
a little snuggy you know right right
well and and the the the schwarzkas on
it is perfect like you couldn't get any
more better branding for the republican
party than yes it's like oh let's go
brandon is not some sort of uh
vulgar slur because i remember when when
the news came out about uh
uh schmeck the schmuck and he did his
little uh prank call
uh you know i did a video that was like
the response and he was like oh i'm
beautiful and i'm the victim and it's
like well you you specifically took the
opportunity to
say that and
uh everyone online and on the comments
were like oh let's go brandon is not uh
it's not a vulgar and it's like well
what does it mean it means [ __ ] joe
biden so how is that not vulgar
and now you guys are associated with the
nazis so hey whatever
right well also the anti-vaxxers are
this is another shot and i'm not sure
exactly where this came from
one of our followers here posted this in
the thread but this is another angle of
that sign right and if you look at it if
you look at it you can see the let's go
brandon which they meant let's go
brandon and it looks like something else
is written underneath this on this bed
sheet you can't you can't see it here
and you can't see it on the other video
but it's clearly the same banner that
they have thrown over
this fence rail and of course they have
the nazi flag here but if you look at
this bed sheet and this is why i think
they're bed sheets because you look at
this yeah that's a big piece of fabric
they probably cut one from the it's cut
from the same cloth right right maybe
they cut this banner over here
the let's go brandon banner from the
right let's go brannon brandon yeah
brandon brandon you know i mean you know
you know but also i it might not be
brandon it might be brain brain is it
brain now because brandon may not be two
ends right now maybe it's maybe this is
like it's like
you know cubanon brandon
i think it's that because there's the
there's the yogurt the uh is it dan and
yogurt is that what they do yeah there's
dan on dan
yeah but that's two wins isn't it i
don't know i don't know
yeah it's too you know really honestly
i'm so bad at spelling i would spell
brandon without the d2 i'll admit it
well i mean there's times that you know
if i haven't had four cups of coffee
before i start tweeting i might tweet
brandon without the d
but
but i never i would never put the nazi
swastika on a set of shitty bed sheets
that you know i tore in half but if you
look here at this sign it says
vax the jews
which i find
um to be very interesting that not only
are they what does the bottom say
i i i can't i that's what i was going to
ask if you go
a moon immunity
immunity i don't know i i can't i i know
i i mean sometimes i think maybe they
have code language that we don't
understand or something like maybe
they're getting this from the ivermectin
facebook groups the nazi facebook groups
but i find it very interesting that um
that a bunch of nazis showed up in
orlando
and not only would desantis
uh decide not to just outright just
[ __ ]
say i am not for these people i don't
know who these people are they need to
leave the state they need to stop um
putting out this hate but he wouldn't he
wouldn't even do that like he couldn't
of course because at the end of the day
who are those people they're voters
right voters for the party the
republican party if you piss them off
you'll piss them all off and he's gotta
vote for nazis right right exactly
well it's not even that it's like nazis
have to vote for
white people they have to vote for
people that look like themselves
and so that may do this
and right change their haircut and wear
different styles or say stuff like joe
biden
baby
uh and so yeah it's like you're gonna
vote you know you want the
representation
that looks like you right and ron
desantis is the
is the picture of
of them right he's a white dude in
florida
right well mj's reporting here
apparently he dodged the question again
today i don't even dodge the question in
florida how do you even dodge the
question i don't know i don't know how
you dodge hey do you support nazis like
no you're like no uh
you know what is wrong with you they're
like funny you should ask uh this guy's
gonna take the question like i've i
haven't seen oh you mean you mean about
the uh the million the stockpile right
right that he [ __ ] up and he's like
like let me get someone else
yeah and then they're like we're gonna
ask you again now that we know there's a
stockpile he goes you know what that's a
good question and uh my friend john over
here is gonna take the ant you know
right and he'll take the heat forward
right yeah i mean the other thing he
could do is you know he could then walk
away but oh i can barely breathe cove it
and then just walk away you know
right but
but here we have here we have nazis
not only um you know pairing them and
i'm gonna call them let's go brandon
nazis from now on i don't care who it is
if you're saying let's go brandon
wearing a shirt you're let's go
nazis that's right well you know what
happens when it happens it's just one
also the anti-vaxxers apparently are
anti-semitic so i don't know oh yeah are
you kidding me i don't know how we're
going all of you all of q's anti-semitic
yeah all these anti-vaxxers who are what
does that say at the bottom what is that
i don't know but i had i tried to look
it up on twitter and other people were
also like [ __ ] immunity like nobody knows
but is this last one like mtv maybe like
i don't know like it's like this part
right here it says like in it says
you know no it's folded it's folded
whatever sheet the sheet is full so
go
g-o-y-i-m
this is like you know when you pull up
on someone they got [ __ ] vanity
plates and you're trying to [ __ ]
figure out like that
right you're like
you're like guessing and you got like 15
different guys
i just want to ask the question anyone
watching right now right if you do you
know what this says can you decide i
need it i need to
i
yeah i need to know what this says
because i am honestly confused is it
code
is it a misspelling like brannon or
raymond maybe they just wrote random
letters down at the bottom yeah i don't
know maybe like you know what we didn't
get the rest of the other 26 letters
from the alphabet let's throw those in
lisa says nope
no no can't can't figure that out um
can't go i just say
mmj's taking stabs at it here yeah i
don't know i just i feel like we're
playing
[ __ ] wheel of fortune right now i'm
like can i get a vowel like i don't know
you're right what the bridge between
these letters i don't know i mean
obviously the vax the jesus is very you
know they're outright about that they're
not gonna hide that right which again it
comes back to this point of like oh
you've got
uh
these people who are saying that this is
uh just like the holocaust you're making
you know they're wearing the star of
david oh yeah it's like gross [ __ ] where
they're saying right right and it's the
same people they're comparing the
vaccine to that and you're like are you
kidding me because that's not in any way
the same thing not at all do not try to
make that comparison if you do you are a
terrible shitty horrible human being
right well and the other thing too about
this vax the jews thing like i get what
they're saying like the code word is oh
wait wait somebody said hold on uh
and says goyam means non-jew
okay
um
something then so goyam means non-jew i
didn't know that but then we don't know
what the remaining letters are
right right right and and
yeah oh it's a [ __ ] website hmm oh
it might be a website interesting yeah
so it's a derogatory term okay
that makes sense that makes sense i mean
it's hard it's hard to make out [ __ ]
terrible these people are [ __ ]
[ __ ] the worst of the worst like
right right well this is the republican
party though right but also it's like
these are the republican voters that ron
desantis wants to vote for him standing
up here on this overpass right
it's
he's not going to insult him because he
wants these tens of people to make sure
he gets their votes i mean he may need
him i mean really he may [ __ ] need
him he may need him but what about this
sign the backs to jews obviously we we
can we know what they're saying right
these people these tpo are [ __ ]
racist they're nazis um we know what
they're trying to say right right we get
they're also attacking a population
that's like point two percent of the
world right but but here which is
[ __ ] insane and so bad but here's the
thing like just the words alone like we
know their direction but honestly like
i i want all people to get vaccinated so
i'm not like like the code here is isn't
for like people like us right and what i
mean by that
here's what i mean you gotta understand
when white people are talking out loud
like this
they're they're sometimes sometimes
you're being derogatory towards a
certain group to warn them right but
sometimes they're speaking in code to
other white people right
because vax
jews getting vaccinated right
anyone getting vaccinated is not a bad
thing right exactly but they claim the
vaccine that's right so if we're going
to say that then we are going back to
the chamber right right so what they're
trying to do is they're trying to send
the signal to anti-vaxxers right and
these anti-maskers and the anti-mandate
groups that hey
we're with you
we're with you we're with you the nazis
we are with you that's what they're
trying to signal here to those right
they're not trying to signal to us
because like vax the jews like in itself
if there wasn't like the nazi flags and
stuff and all that like i would want all
people to be vaccinated and i wouldn't
be surprised if some of these people
were pro-israel but anti-semitic which
is which is really [ __ ] weird isn't
it
the republican party where they
love benjamin netanyahu but don't you
think it's that benjamin netanyahu
fascism that they that they really like
it's not really well yeah it's the
controlling state of it yeah yeah but i
think also it's like it makes no sense
right you've got one like on one side
they
they hate jews and then on the other
side they're pro-israel
because you know they're uh uh
with the united states you know but
again it's that whole like
uh evangelical side of christianity
that's you know wants that end times war
it's you know it ends to a means for
them for you know domination it's so
[ __ ] insane
but these people
are are the but these people are
terrible and it's also you know don't
forget that this was a strong uh
position piece behind cue and that was
what pushed them
and this is just them
disseminating themselves into other
communities uh to push this disgusting
narrative
and well i mean that not only did they
do it with with uh the holocaust and
jews and they continued to do this thing
like they were stars of david they they
like robert kennedy jr is is invoking
the holocaust as if the choice you're
making not to get vaccinated is some
kind of choice that the jews had uh nazi
germany which is really [ __ ] no one
is grouping you as is [ __ ] taking you
in groups and shipping you off somewhere
right no one's doing it this is a choice
that you have to either take the vaccine
or not and you're not get able to get
cheeseburger cheesecake because of it
it's not right it's not anyone else's
problem the other person taking care of
people in a in a population
to make sure that everyone is safe and
does not die and right trying to make a
comparison to something that was a
horrific event
in the world where people were being
killed and died it's really [ __ ]
gross but the other gross thing they do
is when they do when they were doing
like this cheesecake factory burger king
thing right um where they would compare
it to segregation as well because they
do those
it's the holocaust and the segregation
like like they do the those two things
black people could just take off their
skin in the south right exactly they
want oppression so badly oh yeah you
know the the uh the comparison that
people will make well like i'm you know
you got [ __ ]
uh what's this but this is this is this
but this is gabe this is this
you know i grew up in white culture i
know it well right this is this
affirmative action uh dichotomy this
voodoo [ __ ] that they have where they're
like oh
these these poor black people get
advantages because they're black like no
no no
the whole point is is they are they are
it is institutional
that they do not have those advantages
right and we actually have to put things
in place to make sure that they're not
getting
they're getting treated equally and with
equity let's make it fair right but see
they see it so and it's this this
classism that happens inside white
communities too because in a lot of
white communities there's not people of
color to to
you know inside the community so what
happens is the poor white people are now
the class of people who are denigrated
right right and they're discriminated
against and you know what and and so
that and someone else is totally fine
with it right they've accepted it
because they're in a society in a group
that looks like them right as opposed to
someone who is an outsider doesn't look
like them but that's the whole narrative
is um if i'm oppressed then i get things
like oh welfare queen and you're oh
you're just living off welfare which is
not which is totally not even a real
thing right it's not give you a look and
then look at where what like the red
states are the ones who need the most
aid well i mean they do receive the most
federal aid right and especially for
especially in the states that there are
senators who deny further federal
funding
that would surely help build those
people back who could those senators be
i don't
i don't know probably the ones trending
today um speaking of that um let's see
let's let's let's see we had chris cuomo
j crew uh john kennedy speaking of
senators let's let's see if we can go
over there to do the uh tweety treats
real quick we got about uh we got about
10 minutes left in the show here in the
second hour
let's see if we can find this of course
lindsey graham is trending but jaker did
you see senator john kennedy said
something about the supreme court pick
would be somebody like j crew or some
[ __ ] yeah some i saw someone mention it
in the chat when we were talking during
during a discussion a private gop
luncheon of course is at a private gop
luncheon about president biden's
forthcoming supreme court justice pick
senator john kennedy said he was quote a
a nominee a nominee who knows a law book
from a j crew catalog which i i don't
know fashion very well right i just i'm
not a you i if anyone can tell i'm not
like a fashion aficionado but
i do know that j.crew has sell sweaters
i think right yeah
well it's sweaters shirts it's it's
basically more it's like preppy gear you
know okay so it's
i buy my chinos i buy a shirt you know
that kind of thing right right
so so what does that even mean like what
is he trying to say i don't i actually
don't know i mean obviously he's trying
to be racist
to a room of racist people and again
he's speaking in code but like when i've
seen j crew i'm like well i think i know
what that is i had to look it up i'm
like oh
right so a nominee who knows a law book
from a j.crew catalog so basically
he is i'm assuming i haven't read the
full quote here but he is making mention
or attempting to make a dig at someone
who doesn't just look the part but is
the part right so knows a law book
versus
looks like a lawyer
but can't tell the difference if you
were to put a catalog in front of them
or not so basically uneducated and
unprepared and unqualified so basically
in costume is what he's yeah he's just
i mean he's being a [ __ ] racist
exactly yeah it's a dog whistle for
saying uh he's a racist and he doesn't
want someone in there because he's
making the claim that a black woman
could not be qualified which is
anything further just absolutely
ridiculous that what what is crazy is
that that the reason why they're saying
this [ __ ] out loud is because there's
more [ __ ] qualified black women to be
on the court then there are [ __ ]
white men at this point and it really is
laughable that the country doesn't even
[ __ ] know that they don't know that
like or almost 70 of all degrees that
are that are [ __ ] awarded by
universities and colleges in this
country are two black women they're like
the most educated group of people and
that's exactly who i would want to
represent the country not only are they
a person who has uh who can relate to
someone right like i'm hispanic and
that's another person that i can relate
to in a community of other non-white
people right right and
why not have a face why not have
it's it's like whenever there's a
superhero or or an action hero where
you're like oh my god that person looks
like me right someone who is indian or
hispanic or black or whatever you've got
that little kid who looks at that and
says
oh my god they're just like me i can be
that like there's a possibility as
opposed to i only see white people doing
this so you know what for me mentally i
think
oh great well i guess that's not even in
the cards for me right and that's the
big difference as well as the fact that
these old white wrinkly ball sack men as
you call them earlier well i'll continue
to go right they
they are afraid and that's what i was
saying earlier is they are so afraid of
the fact that there's a possibility that
somebody could do a better job than them
and not look like them well that's what
they're scared of they're scared of that
because let's face it women black women
but women in general are going to fix
our country i i trust exactly like as
soon as we hand this [ __ ] and history
has shown us right those women
are the ones that have fixed our [ __ ]
right right oh
men [ __ ] everything up absolutely
everything and i'm not just talking
about government i'm talking about
[ __ ] everything right men [ __ ] [ __ ]
up like you wouldn't believe it's not
even it's not even a contest and women
are always coming behind us and cleaning
the [ __ ] up and making sure that it's
fixed and making sure that it operates
correctly and i believe the sooner we
can get to a place to where women are
because women do a better job of
governing too i don't know if you've
ever watched like
children playing in a room and a man's
like oh do this do that they're not
listening and mom walks in boom
done mom's there everything's cool and
it it ain't because it ain't because
they're terrified of mom it's because
moms know how to govern women know how
to govern they know how to set policy
they know how to administrate like this
is a thing that women do very [ __ ]
well and the reason why is because
they're super [ __ ] smart they're
super [ __ ] educated and for anyone to
be offended that joe biden's like i'm
gonna take the uh a black woman who is
likely the most educated
person in the country who is more
qualified than most white men would ever
dream of being to be a supreme court
justice pick so not only do we have a
very smart very qualified supreme court
justice pick but it reflects what the
country looks like like you said it
reflects what they look like to be
offended and insulted by that and you're
a [ __ ] bigot you're right
you're a [ __ ] bigot and let's not
forget the only difference between
reagan
and trump nominating or or uh getting a
female
justice
is the fact that joe biden said it was a
black woman right and the only
difference between woman and black woman
is black right right and that's the
problem that's the real problem that
they have and that is the unfortunate
truth for that party where they will
push that narrative that a black woman
though even more
overqualified than most people who are
running for office or representatives
they are afraid that that person is
going to take their job because they are
no longer the person that's going to be
in power to get these good old boys and
support them throughout their you know
their their push into politics and more
power it's like
they are just afraid at the end of the
day and they they're sensitive
snowflakes they're exactly what they
project onto other people
that's they're weak that's it what it is
they're weak speaking of weak white ball
sex
oh
mr mr putin putin's putin's puppy here
yeah um
exclusive from axios senator josh holly
is calling on biden administration to
drop
drop long-standing u.s support tell me
you work for putin without telling me
you work for putin well you know
this is this is really [ __ ] weird
right like united states sitting
senators are pushing russia's agenda
putin's agenda here and it and it's
it's hard to tell if they're doing it to
get support
amongst the masses because it's this own
the libtard [ __ ] like oh anything to
make joe bideful unsuccessful and if joe
biden loses a war with putin
then donald trump will be elected or
something right right anything any
general they are pro the republican
party is this pro anything that is
anti-biden
that's what it is
if there is anyone
this is it is so it is so insane to
think that we are at a point now where
we want to support
russia
over
anyone else
right this has been a slow
slow rumbles you know in uh building up
to this moment of like yep we [ __ ]
love putin we love russia we are pro
kremlin like that what you'd think back
to the 80s we're 30 years ago or yeah or
40 years ago am i doing the right yeah i
don't know
the 80s 80s yeah yeah 40 years well
god damn i was born in the 80s it was
it's getting to be 40 years yeah jerk
depending on where you're at in the 80s
but you look at that and you're like
never would you have thought when you
were like oh we're cold war and this and
that that you would ever find yourself
in a country that was fighting against
them to now say you know what party of
reagan reagan right here mr gorbachev
tear down right wall like he's he's they
give him so much credit for ending the
cold war and here they are
trying to build that [ __ ] back up
it's just [ __ ] ridiculous um there's
probably a hundred other things why this
[ __ ] idiot could be trending but
obviously this is the one
um you know because he is putin's puppy
here and he's he's pushing putin's
agenda rather it's to own the libs or
he's a putin puppy which either way he
is putin's puppy um like ron johnson and
the rest and if he's not right now then
he's trying to be he will be he's
probably knows in his way in
to be
he [ __ ] will be we're 15 at 59
minutes into the second hour we only
have a couple minutes left i want to
make the announcement again um we got
this exciting interview we'll be
announcing it we'll watch our twitter um
go follow um us on twitter
at tonymichaelspod at the tony michaels
and i am gabe sanchez follow us there we
are working with some partners to get
this this interview out into let's play
the let's play the clip one more time
yeah let's play it one more time and
then we'll talk about it now which
brings me to one thing that everyone
wants to know because this is the story
that everyone wants to hear um stuart
where's an eye patch we've seen it in
the in the uh
in the mug shots
and in the tunnel videos like we said
earlier the spider whole
uh tactical whole he did not have an eye
patch so there is a story going around
that he shot himself in the eye um i
don't know how that is what it is do you
guys know the story and can you tell us
the story of how stuart seemed to have
an eye patch okay this is three stories
there is the event
okay and the facts that happened
and there's also this story he told
there's
which is mostly lie
there's also
what i believe actually happened and it
took me 20 years to piece it together
and then
there's the second event which is why he
stopped wearing a prosthetic eye
um i guess i'll start with him shooting
himself in the face
shooting himself in the face so if you
want to hear how stuart rose shot
himself in the face but more importantly
there's about there's over an hour of
content there
of them talking about who stuart rhodes
is why why they think he did what he did
what is
what his motivations were so we'll be
announcing that interview um and we'll
be posting this clip on social media as
well we're going to try to work that out
with our partner we're trying to work
with um to get all this information out
there to get it to as many people as
possible so that people understand
exactly what these people were thinking
on january 6th and dakota which dakota
there is is stewart road's son dakota
adams um and and tasha adams is his
estranged future ex-wife um but they
she's got a website you can go follow
her on twitter we talk about that in the
interview um it's it's it's a great
interview they um they actually
they put some human element into stuart
rhodes and the oath keepers and there's
a lot of stuff in there like you will
surprise you like it surprised me some
of the stuff they said like i would
never dream that that was what they were
gonna say yeah uh about the oath keepers
or stuart like there was some stuff of
course some of it is you know very
predictable but right um some of it is
not even even the stuff about the
formation and what people believe why
right
versus what it actually was right
because this organization was not it was
not new when donald trump became
president this organization uh harkens
back a long time ago and they also
describe in the interview um why stewart
has this um
cult-like type kind of thing
where he inherited it from so they talk
about that in the interview as well so
it's it's definitely worth the watch i
hope that we can air it tomorrow or
friday on the podcast um we will
announce that we will let you know when
that is going to air um also when we do
air it obviously we are going to post it
separately we're not sure on our
partners um who we're partnering with
that we're going to get them to post it
there on our page but make sure to go
subscribe to the youtube channel just in
case um
hit the bell notifications and hit the
like but you know all the good stuff
that you're supposed to say you know all
the all the what the youtubers say yeah
yeah yeah all that kind of good stuff so
and and don't forget tomorrow
every single weekday noon eastern 11
noon eastern 11 central right here on
you twitter twitch
the tony michaels podcast
and we surfed the trendy trends in the
tweety tweets are you gonna join us
tomorrow you're gonna be around tomorrow
yeah i'll be around you'll be around
okay good good good well until tomorrow
until tomorrow noon surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking